i'm stuart varney i'm harris faulkner
i'm chris wallace and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday may 26 2021
i'm dave anthony there's more scrutiny
than ever on
china over covid's origins and if the
virus
got out of a lab it is absolutely
imperative that we understand what
happened so we can prevent
another 3 million lives or perhaps next
time 30 million lives from perishing
if the chinese communist party is going
to be conducting viral research that
endangers the world
the world must unite to stop them from
doing that we speak with former
secretary of state mike pompeo
i'm lisa brady the u.s hits another
vaccination milestone
but a global race with kovid continues
we need to stay nimble on this pandemic
we can't throw our hands up and say
we've beaten it
when we know that there are raging fires
around the world
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
where did kovat 19 come from
we know in china but how
there was a lot of talk about a wet
market and wuhan that
it might have come from a bat maybe a
human ate an
animal that ate a bat or it got out of
the lab
the lab in wuhan that studies viruses
a wall street journal story the other
day added to that theory citing u.s and
other intelligence
that three lab workers got sick in
november 2019
hospitalized with coronavirus-like
symptoms health and human services
secretary javier becerra wants a deeper
investigation give
international experts the independence
to fully assess the source of the virus
and the early days of the outbreak but
republican senator rick scott tells fox
we have to understand the government of
china is a despicable
government over 500 000 americans have
died because of their cover-up which
china of course denies calling it a
hyped-up lie
so i've had access to information for a
long time which
caused me to believe that the most
likely conclusion for what happened
former secretary of state mike pompeo is
now a fox news contributor
the most likely hypothesis for what
happened
was that this was a virus that was being
worked on it was being souped up amped
up
in the wuhan institute of virology and
there was a leak
an escape from that laboratory i've been
talking about that for well over a year
now
dave people thought i had a tinfoil hat
on they thought i was crazy
well it turns out every piece of
evidence since we've been speaking about
this
points in that direction and now
scientists from all across the world are
trying to get to the right side of
history and talk about this as if they
they too accept that this is a at least
a working hypothesis because
none of us can prove this in the end
because the chinese communist party
doesn't want you to know dave doesn't
want your listeners to know
they know who patient zero was they know
where this began
and yet they have denied every
organization that has sought to get
information
about this virus and how it's spread and
hide it they've disappeared journalists
they've disappeared doctors
they've put a bit information they've
destroyed uh viruses that will certainly
be a piece of evidence about where this
began the chinese communist party
has covered up this cataclysmic event
that happened to the world this past
year and change they need to be held
accountable for it
and if i'm wrong if it turns out it
didn't come from the the lab they're in
wuhan
they have the ability to disprove it
they ought to make it public where it
came from because they of course know
the answer to that
what can be done to try to get answers
everyone says we want to get answers we
want to
we want to get but how do you actually
get inside
this lab or into china and actually do
that kind of investigation
so you can't have a formal investigation
if you're uh if you're begging for
information indeed when
when the world health organization sent
the committee there it was it was a
charade it was a complete farce
they were presented curated information
they couldn't go see what they wanted to
and talk to who they wanted to
so you can't without the permission of
the chinese communist party you'll never
have an
investigation to get you anything unless
they change their tune
how do you give them to change your tune
you impose real costs on them there's
lots of things one could do for example
you could kick them out of the world
health organization
right dave this is an organization
that's supposed to stop
global pandemics and yet this was an
organization that facilitated by
being part of the cover-up this very
pandemic the chinese communist party has
no right to be a member of an
organization when it is working in ways
that are undermining the very most
important right you had one job
at the who stop a pandemic and the
chinese communist party co-opted into
not doing that
uh there are lots of ways one can impose
costs on the chinese communist party
i'll give you another example we
shouldn't hold the genocide olympics
in beijing next year to think that we're
going to set athletes from all across
the world to go be part of this
this this this this important athletic
event
with global pride on the line to let a
country that's committing genocide in
western china
and covered up a virus that killed over
three million people around the world
outrageous the ioc should change the
venue for this and if you have to delay
the olympics a year to do so
so be it there are many ways we can
impose costs on the chinese communist
party and if the costs are high enough
the chinese communist party will
ultimately be forced to come clean about
what they did
so if you think if if you were still
secretary of state and president trump
was in office the u.s wouldn't go to
those olympics in your opinion
i can certainly tell you what i would
have recommended to the president
this will happen again this lab is still
operating
they are likely still conducting the
same kinds of researches which are
amping up souping up viruses inside of
their laboratory
there are connections to the chinese
military inside of that these
bio safety issues inside that laboratory
they exist even as we're on
even on this interview right now we
could end up suffering this
again it is absolutely imperative that
we understand what happens so we can
prevent
another three million lives or perhaps
next time 30 million lives
from perishing if the chinese communist
party is going to be conducting viral
research that endangers the world
the world must unite to stop them from
doing that the man who succeeded mike
pompeo as secretary of state
anthony blinken was in the middle east
yesterday as they cease fire holds
between
israelis and palestinians after 11 days
of airstrikes on gaza to stop militant
rockets fired into israel the united
states
fully supports israel's right to defend
itself against attacks blankets also
coordinating foreign aid to help the
people of gaza where there's a lot of
destruction
and to keep that money away from hamas
militants funded by iran
all as blinking and the biden
administration try to get the us
back into the international nuclear deal
president trump pulled us out of
to put iran back in the nuclear box
that the deal constructed but pompeo
thinks that is a terrible idea
it is an enormous mistake to think that
you can cut a deal with the iranians
while you have hezbollah and hamas and
the houthis all
iranian bacteria groups continuing to
inflict terror in the region
and undermining our allies and friends
while the iranians
take american money and american support
so with the current ceasefire what
should the administration be doing to to
try to ensure that the rockets and the
air strikes don't
return the cease-fire i'm glad it's
holding
the loss of every life matters uh
civilians killed
uh whether they are in israel or in the
gaza strip
they're human beings they matter an
awful lot but make no mistake about it
what the iranians
stand is a forceful leader and they
understood that president trump would
impose real costs on them if they did
something like launch 4000 rockets
from gaza into israel aimed with the
intention
of killing civilians this is what the
administration must do they must impose
real costs on the primary
uh primary provider of arms and weapons
and money that is fueling this terrorism
in the region that is undermining
the abraham accords and stability in the
middle east
if we if america continues play footsie
with the iranians it will cost
untold number of lives in the middle
east it will create more instability
and young american kids are greater risk
that someday they'll have to go to those
places
to create the stability that is
important and vital to america's own
interests
we we never we never put the united
states in a position where the leaders
in the region including the iranians
didn't understand
that america was serious about
protecting a friend and ally israel
there have been progressives who have
been saying that israel is the one
committing humanitarian abuses with the
deaths of civilians in gaza with all the
airstrikes more than 200 of those dead
were
palestinians and there were some women
and children among them so
what's your response to that every
single life lost
is the direct responsibility of the
terrorists who started this conflict and
forced the israelis
to defend their own sovereign territory
we'd certainly do it here in the united
states
someone who's launching rockets into our
country when i hear american leaders
create a moral equivalence between those
two there's just a hint of anti-semitism
almost every time where somehow this
state the jewish homeland
is held to a standard that is different
than any other country in the world is
held to we
we we would not we we would not talk
about moral equivalence between any
country that was under attack
when all they were doing was trying to
respond to keep their own people safe
you yourself are going to this very
region correct
well i'm going over there as a private
citizen i
i haven't scheduled yet any meetings
with the government
i actually spoke with secretary blink
and i told him why i was going over
there i only wish
my predecessor john kerry would have
behaved the same way
i made a commitment i wouldn't talk i
wouldn't undermine american foreign
policy i'm no longer the secretary
i'm going over there to do what's in
america's best interest
i'll always do that do you believe that
john kerry
did try to undermine your work with iran
and and you would what you did with iran
and
undoing the nuclear deal that he was so
involved in before you guys took office
oh of course he did he was meeting with
an american adversary
he was meeting with foreign minister
zarif a terrorist himself
he was meeting with officers reef with
the direct intention of telling him
don't worry just wait
there'll be another election there'll be
another time the pressure campaign the
amazing pressure that the united states
was putting on the iranian regime
he was telling them just hang on if you
can just wait until this election and
uh when the new administration comes in
you'll get the economic relief that
you're
that your people d need and of course
that appears to be what this
administration is intended upon doing
how will you avoid people saying that
you
were trying to do the same thing to the
biden administration going to the middle
east oh goodness
oh goodness because because my meetings
are everything i do is going to be
public
uh save for the party that i'm going to
attend the director of mossad who was my
counterpart when i was a director is
retiring
i'm going over there to attend his
retirement party and then i have some
private meetings with some commercial
business people
for the reason for my visit russia is
another big issue
from election meddling to cyber attacks
in the u.s
and more president biden will have a
face-to-face meeting his first
with russian president vladimir putin
next month
in geneva i hope that president biden in
that meeting will
make clear to the russians american
expectations the job is to protect
america that's his role
and we saw what the what happened with
the airplane that was traveling over
belarus
we should find out if the russians were
connected to this
he should tell vladimir putin that we're
not going to let him finish the
nordstream
2 pipeline something that the trump
administration had worked diligently on
and yet this administration appears
prepared to
give a bunch of money to finish that
pipeline out when they destroy a
pipeline here at home they say
you know those 10 000 jobs in america
don't matter i i remember dave
you know there was all this talk about
how uh trump and pompeo well we weren't
tough enough on russia
but it was the obama biden
administration that allowed crimea to be
taken by the russians it was
the obama biden administration that
wouldn't provide defensive weapons
systems to the ukrainians
we built out our military if you think
vladimir putin was happy when president
trump approved the biggest defense
spending increase in an awfully long
time i can assure you he was not
we need to protect american interest you
got to put america first
so this pipeline that you're speaking of
involves what exactly
so it's a russian pipeline being built
from russia to serve
northern northern parts of europe most
importantly germany
and will give the russians enormous
capacity and
time of conflict to constrict that
that's moving through the pipeline
in a way that would harm germany and so
it puts germany beholden to russia
this pipeline has national security
implications for
our nato partner germany and for other
nato countries and president trump said
this is nonsense
why would we give us money to nato
support nato
while the russians are selling natural
gas
to our nato partner germany it makes no
sense it increases risk for germany and
therefore
to nato and the united states and we put
sanctions in places
and appears that president biden heads
down the path on lifting those sanctions
and allowing that pipeline to continue
to be built
former secretary of state mike pompeo
now a fox news contributor thank you
very much for joining us
dave thank you very much sir have a good
day
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary
coming up half of american adults
are now fully vaccinated against covet
we have more work to do to meet the
president's goal of 70
of adult americans with one shot by july
4th and white house senior coveted
adviser andy slavitt says if you're not
vaccinated you're at risk when the virus
looks for a place to spread
and it doesn't spread to a vaccinated
person it will look for you
so the cdc is reiterating its guidance
that it's safe without a mask in most
places if you're vaccinated
but to mask up and continue other
precautions if you're not
the seven day average of covet cases in
the u.s continues to drop
falling to under 23 000 as signs of a
more normal life
return we got to understand we're
leaving kova behind
we can't live in the gripakova the rest
of our lives it is going to be in our
past
new york city mayor bill de blasio this
week announcing a return
to full in-person learning this fall
calling september a whole different ball
game though so far
only about 14 percent of 12 to 15 year
olds have received
their first dose of the pfizer vaccine
newly authorized for emergency use in
that age group
and less than a quarter of 16 and 17
year olds have had both doses
but for now we head into memorial day
weekend with the adult population
topping that 50 percent mark it's a huge
deal
dr cyra madad is senior director of new
york city's system-wide special
pathogens program
and we are actually seeing the
translation of the
vaccination program roll out across the
nation in terms of
the number of reduced cases that we're
seeing the number of reduced
hospitalizations and death
so if we're just looking at for example
you know the 70 average of cases it's
reached you know it's one of its
all-time lows of 27 000 cases
for the first time you know uh since uh
uh
you know since many many months and so
we're looking at a substantial
decrease in the number of community
transmissions so we have definitely
entered a new phase of this pandemic
where we can safely say that the acute
phase of the pandemic is likely very
close to coming to an end here in the
united states
now the cdc has a new report out on
breakthrough infections
emphasizing again how rare that they are
um but there are some ongoing questions
about whether
we're going to need a booster shot are
you concerned that could
deter people from getting a shot in the
first place or
that people won't show up for boosters
months from now
how bad would that be well i think first
it's important to understand that the
currently authorized kova 19 vaccines
that we have here in the united states
are highly safe and effective against
all
circulating variants of concern so the
notion of the
booster shots is one of those things
where we don't know if we need it and it
may be very likely that we don't need
booster shots
um in the future but it's one of those
things where once we start seeing that
there are increased number of cases
caused by
you know vaccine-induced immunity um you
know
lowering that's when we know we may need
booster shots but i i
i'm a bit skeptical on it because when
you look at the way that our immune
system works it's very complex
it's not just about the antibodies that
are produced but it's also about
you know the memory cells the t cells
for example and if we compare it to
sars back in 2003 you're seeing that you
know we have really great
you know memory cells you know that can
exist for years or decades
it's just these variants that are
circulating the new ones that we may not
even know about as we know the the
situation is very different around the
world so if we have
a new variant of concern that has a
significant impact on our current
vaccine-induced immunity
we may need boosters down the line but i
think the bottom line is right now
in this moment the vaccines that we have
are highly effective against all the
circulating variants
so if you haven't gotten vaccinated
again right now it's certainly time to
get vaccinated
we do still have a long way to go with
getting kids vaccinated
should parents be concerned about this
rare heart issue
that's been reported which may not be
linked to the pfizer vaccine
that's correct so i think first you know
the heart problem in
the young vaccine recipients that cdc is
investigating then there's a few dozen
cases of
myocarditis which is an inflammation of
the heart muscle
right now there is no connection to the
mrna uh
vaccines and the baseline um of the
number of myocardial cases that we
normally see
you know be besides we ever had you know
in a pandemic is the same so right now
there's just
uh keeping a close eye they want
providers to just be aware of this
but you know right now their benefits
certainly outweigh the risks and right
now
there isn't a connection associated with
it i think it's also important to
to probably also mention that when we
talk about you know myocardial
corditis it's a frequently mild and
self-limiting symptoms
you know can include abnormal heart
rhythm shortness of breath and chest
pain
and so it's not necessarily a serious
condition
on its own but certainly we want to
further investigate
certainly school districts are already
planning for the fall even though the
current school year is not over yet the
two
biggest districts in the country are
taking different approaches
both new york and la say they will be
back to full in-person learning but new
york says
it won't even offer any remote learning
anymore
la still plans to offer remote learning
just in case anyone needs it
it does seem like masks will still be in
the mix
what do you think school should be like
this fall
so you know i think it's one of those
things where as our vaccination
um you know continues to increase in
terms of
uh community immunity levels we'll be in
a very
different you know situation come you
know the the fall and if we're looking
at for example some of the
the forecasts that are being done by
many
prominent models uh including the
institute for health metrics
and evaluation at the university of uh
washington they predict fewer than 7 000
daily cases by mid-august than fewer
than 120 deaths and again
we'll take that with a grain of salt
because these are just models but at the
same time i think that just knowing that
we're going to have
continuous mass requirements in schools
with the distance thing that
cdc has put in i think right now it's
it's a it's a good guidance and it will
likely change
as our you know dynamics of community
transmission continues to decrease so
i think come august things will look
different the world is
is really still debating where the new
coronavirus
came from what's your take on the wuhan
lab
and the kind of research federal health
officials say the u.s
was was not approving um at least with
u.s funds
well you know i think there certainly
needs to be a much more thorough
investigation right now
the types of investigations that have
been done
are really just scratching the surface
we really don't have really great
answers
and in order for us to get to the bottom
of the origin we certainly need to have
much more transparency and collaboration
on the global scale along with various
governments including china
and we need to ensure that we understand
uh you know the the full picture so i
certainly do
think you know all options are on the
table but there are very there's
still compelling evidence against the
natural origin of the virus and there's
also compelling evidence
of other theories but until we have more
information until we're able to do much
more
widespread investigation and have larger
teams and more resources deployed
we we won't be able to get to the to the
bottom line here
if this was a lab accident and i
realized that's a big if but
assume it was for a second how common
are these
kinds of accidents is this something
that you know doctors like you feared
could happen oh absolutely i've been in
the field of bio-preparedness for
many many years and when we talk about
you know
infectious disease outbreaks one of the
phases or one of the aspects that we
often look at is not just the
unintentional infections of these
outbreaks but the intentional or the
deliberate use of infectious disease
um you know to to harm civilians and the
general population
and so we look at multiple different
ways that that can happen it could be
unintentional in terms of a lab leak and
there are if you go back
and take a walk down history there have
been instances of it and there's been um
intentional as well so i i think that
you know is this something new
no it's not something new if you look
back at history but we certainly just
need to
get to the bottom line and ensure that
you know there's accountability
um of what's what's happening organizers
of this summer's tokyo olympics that the
postponed olympics from last year
say they are happening in july even if
japan has a state of emergency
still in effect the u.s state department
has come out though and urged people
not to travel there is that advisory
overkill at this point or is that level
of caution still needed
i still do think there's a level caution
that's needed because in the united
states we're in a very
different and unique position given our
vaccination rates and the low number of
community transmission that we're
now starting to see across the united
states but around the world we're in a
very
uh different picture in fact these are
one of the worst days
of this pandemic for other countries and
so i think we need to make sure we keep
our guard up and now put ourselves in a
situation where even though we have
uh we're vaccinated we're now going into
an area with very high levels of
community transmission with variants um
that we may not even have discovered or
known about that may have an impact
on our vaccine-induced immunity so i do
think that it's it's important to
continue to
um uh you know abide by covet behavior
and very high levels of community
transmission in countries that have
uncontrolled
um ongoing uh raging pandemic there what
do you think is the bigger
test for the effectiveness of the
vaccines
will it be this summer or will the real
test be
the the fall winter flu season when it
comes around again
i do think when we start going back into
the colder months that's when we
uh you know we'll see uh more you know
overall kind of test to our vaccine and
induce the immunity as well as as time
progresses because as we know the
the pandemic continues to rage on across
the world this pandemic is far from over
if you're looking at countries around
the world where a number of countries
haven't even seen a
one kova 19 vaccine administered yet you
know there are several countries that
have started it we've only administered
over a billion
uh vaccines around the world which is
nowhere near where we need
and so there's certainly a very high
chance and possibility that you're gonna
with the ongoing transmission of the
virus there's more opportunity for it to
mutate and there's more opportunities to
have
new emerging variants of concern or high
consequence variants of concern which we
haven't seen yet
so i think all those things certainly uh
are a possibility right now
so i think the key here is we need to
stay nimble on this pandemic we can't
throw our hands up and say we've beaten
it
when we know that there are raging fires
around the world
one last thing one last follow-up
because you know a lot of people seem
very excited to get out and do things
this summer
um that they weren't doing last summer
does that worry you
oh yeah i think in the united states in
particular i think
given that we have such great uh you
know vaccination rates that are ongoing
we have low numbers of community
transmission i feel much more confident
at the same time i think those that are
not vaccinated remain
highly still at risk including children
i have three children of my own i have a
one and a half
a five and a seven year old so you know
even though myself and my husband are
fully vaccinated
we continue to wear a mask in indoor
spaces we continue to be very cautious
of what we're doing and what activities
we're engaging in because we still know
we're in still in the middle of a
pandemic there's still cases happening
and our children are still at risk right
now and so i just want to make sure
people are cautious
in the decisions that they make
certainly those that are fully
vaccinated
can uh resume many activities uh like
they did prior to the pandemic
but with that said until we have um more
people vaccinated until we're able to
have more vaccines and arms around the
world
we're always going to be in this kind of
gray area where
we feel comfortable and we should
celebrate the small wins but also know
that there's still a lot more work to be
done ahead of us
dr cyrus thank you very much as always
for your time
of course thank you for having me on
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind president biden's
covet relief is quickly devolving
into shocking stories of waste fraud and
abuse
biden bellowed on covet relief this
historic legislation is about rebuilding
the backbone of this country and giving
people in this nation
working people middle class folks people
who built the country
a fighting chance end quote that was the
promise
but that's not the reality what biden
didn't tell americans
is their money is actually being sent
overseas for projects bearing little
relation to the public health crisis
scuba gear in uruguay gas turbine
engines in canada
hiv research in ukraine and management
consulting services in fiji
are all part of what democrats consider
urgent
emergency relief even quote
disinformation and fake news
tv radio and multimedia project for pd
in south america via the state
department
these are just some of the grants listed
at pandemicoversite.gov
where the government's independent
inspectors general have created an
important resource
for americans to monitor government aid
in just a few minutes i was able to
learn the democrats have budgeted to
build
two gazebos at guantanamo bay cuba
the budget for the 20 foot by 30 foot
and 16 foot by 20 foot structures
is 600 000 for two gazebos
roughly five million dollars went to
russia for
civil society grants 24 million dollars
went to syria to encourage them to
wash their hands the pandemic response
accountability committee
prac chaired by department of justice
inspector general michael horowitz
created the website to reveal who
received the pandemic funding
how much they received and how they're
spending the money
the prac urges americans to use the site
to report
fraud waste abuse and mismanagement
of the funding going forward though
government waste is a sad
fact of life and a reason many of us
prefer to keep the role of government
limited
the unprecedented volume of covet relief
aid
makes it a prime target for fraud
already we've seen
cases of fraud prosecuted with regard to
cares act funding in march the
department of justice reported it had
charged nearly 500 people
in criminal schemes to collect pandemic
aid money
and that's the low-hanging fruit those
are the people here in the united states
who are applying for funds
what happens when that money is being
scattered abroad in countries over which
american law enforcement
has no jurisdiction it's as if the
pandemic is nothing more than a pretext
to spend money democrats can't justify
through the regular such as it is budget
process
who knows what else will find relief
funds buying in the coming years
transparency is going to be more
important than ever horowitz and his
fellow inspectors general
have a huge job to do if they want to
trace how budgeted money
ultimately got spent the job is made
even bigger by the fact that so many
media outlets who would normally be
counted on to report
waste fraud and abuse have become
cheerleaders
for the party in power it is incumbent
upon
american citizens and responsible media
to watch closely where these emergency
dollars end up
and to hold accountable those who
perpetuate waste fraud and abuse
because what we are being told is not
what is actually happening this is
former congressman jason chaffetz you
can find my podcast
jason in the house at foxnewspodcast.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on
american life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes